LIZ SCHWAB: Hello,
good afternoon.
Thank you for coming.
Welcome to Google.
For those joining
via YouTube, thanks
for joining us and sorry we're
running a few minutes late.
My name is Liz Schwab.
I work on the
Community Affairs team
here in our Cambridge office,
and we're thrilled to have,
today, the third events in our
Thought Leader series here.
Joining us again is Kara Miller
from WGBH's Innovation Hub.
And with her today is Nigel
Jacob from the Mayor's Office
of New Urban Mechanics and Kent
Larson from MIT's Media Lab
Changing Places group.
So we're excited to talk
about innovative cities today.
Kara, the stage is yours.
KARA MILLER: OK, so we're
really excited to talk
about this topic of cities,
where they're going,
how they're doing
innovative things.
And I'm just going to throw
the first thing to you, Kent.
We were talking about
this a little bit
before we came up here.
There's this massive migration,
in many parts of the world,
to cities.
We now have more than half
the people in the world living
in cities, which is kind
of this incredible thing,
these little sort
of dots on a map.
How is that changing
us in how we live?
KENT LARSON: Well, we're
becoming an urbanized planet.
Europe and the US, by the
way, are heavily urbanized.
And 90% of the population
growth from here
on out will take
place in cities.
So we have to focus on cities.
I think it's a
great thing in that,
if you talk to most young
people, increasingly,
they want to live in the city.
They want to live
in neighborhoods
where they can live and work
and play and shop and go
to bars and great restaurants
right in the city.
We had a conference at Harvard
last weekend about India.
And it's a little
different there.
That's where women find
opportunities in education,
and people can find
employment and opportunities
and leave the kind of
problems of rural life.
So there are a lot of pressures
forcing people to the city,
and, I think, in most cases,
they find better lives there.
KARA MILLER: Nigel,
one of the writers
who's talked about people
moving to the city-- and this
is in America, too, the
increasing draw of cities.
Alan Ehrenhalt once
said to me, you
know, you've got a generation
of people who grew up,
who sat in the suburbs, watching
"Seinfeld" and "Friends" and
"Sex in the City," and they
were like, wait a minute,
I want to live like that.
So you do see the sky-rocketing
home prices in cities
all over the place.
What kind of pressure does
that income increased interest
in cities place on
you if you're actually
part of city government?
NIGEL JACOB: Sure, so I think
lots of different pressures--
I'll say that the
urbanization is happening
not only in terms of
suburbs into cities,
but also internationally.
We're seeing people
that are moving
from the country, the sort of
rural setting in one country,
coming to Boston or to New
York, or what have you.
And in one way or the
other, the challenge,
if you're in a leadership
position in the cities,
is to figure out how do create
a policy environment that
is supportive of those things.
There's still a lot of
unanswered questions
around urbanization.
A lot of people, maybe not
that don't skew as young,
there are negative
connotations with density.
Because urbanization, especially
with a city like Boston,
which is physically so small,
this wave of urbanization
will have to lead to density.
And if you live in
a part of the city,
and you believe that
your parking spot is
your god-given right
and that there's
going to be 100 people moving
into your neighborhood,
that's going to be a
really tricky discussion.
So you know it means that, as
a leadership, how [INAUDIBLE]?
How do you facilitate a
negotiation or a process
of engagement with
the public where
there is a real
dialogue happening,
and it's not just the
traditional kind of lip service
that's been done around
civic engagement.
KARA MILLER: Kent,
Mayor Bloomberg,
former mayor of New
York, famously was like,
let's try these
micro apartments,
put people in smaller spaces.
But even if there's
a lot of interest,
let's say, amongst 20-somethings
in living in Manhattan
or Brooklyn or downtown
San Francisco or Cambridge
or Boston, even if
there is that interest,
do you really get to the
point where you're 32,
and you've got a couple of kids,
and your like, 700 square feet,
that's totally fine?
Or will a sort of
younger generation,
like many generations
before them,
say, you know what, no, I want
a yard, 2,000 square feet?
KENT LARSON: Well,
I'll address that,
but I think you need
to start with density.
As what Nigel mentioned, I think
a lot of it is about density.
And density is
neither good nor bad.
It depends how you do it.
And so if you can increase
the density in cities,
you have a lot of good things.
You have greater GDP, higher
income, better restaurants,
more cultural
activities, et cetera.
Or you can have traffic
congestion and pollution
and loss of contact with
nature and crime and disease.
So it's neither good nor bad.
Density he is tricky
because of traffic.
If you're dependent on
private automobiles,
the neighborhoods right.
Increase the density, you're
going have a lot of problems.
So moving away from that, but
to get to your micro unit issue.
It's really in our mind a way
of increasing the density-- one
strategy, so you have the
good stuff without the bad.
It's not that everyone is
going to live in a micro unit
all their life.
But market-rate
housing, like what's
being proposed here in
Kendall Square, for example,
is really good at one
little, narrow segment
of the population-- rich people.
It doesn't provide housing
for graduate students
or junior faculty or young
professionals or families
or elderly people.
And one thing I really
appreciate about Mayor Walsh
is he has a housing
initiative to increase
the density of housing for
those people not served
by market-rate housing.
And micro units is one really
interesting way to do that.
KARA MILLER: When you
talk about density,
what does that
mean on the ground?
It sounds like it means
maybe getting smaller?
And I assume it means
building up, right?
And not having like
a bunch of buildings
that are only a
few stories high.
KENT LARSON:
Density, in my mind,
you define it broadly
as residential density,
but it doesn't necessarily
mean more bulk.
It can mean just using
space more efficiently.
It's density of
enterprises, of companies,
and hopefully
they're in balance,
so you have live
and work in balance.
It's density of third
places and shops and cafes.
So you can define
density broadly.
I think that we tend
to-- I'm an architect.
And you look at what
architects build
tends to be a
very-- particularly
the high-end building-- a very
poor utilization of space.
And you talk about apartments.
It's really kind of silly to
have a bedroom and a living
room side-by-side.
You don't use a
bedroom during the day.
You don't use the
living room at night.
If you stack them and
just did a transition,
you could make both bigger
and both better in half
for 2/3 of the space.
You look at many of the
spaces in office buildings.
They're underutilized
most of the time.
Even the Media Lab, we complain
about not having enough space,
but it's just a poor
utilization of space.
So I think we can do a lot
better without increasing
the bulk.
NIGEL JACOB: So
one of the things
that's happened, I think, in a
socioeconomic sense for people
living in cities, there was
a time in America's past,
in sort of the
post-World War Ii era,
where prosperity was equated
to house size and the number
of cars and so on.
And that's just gone,
for the most part,
for a certain age demographic.
And so I think
increasingly, people just
don't want-- they don't see
the two-car garage as being
a symbol of prosperity.
Because we're still a very
symbolic social species,
and we always want
to give out those
signals that I'm prospering,
but cars are no longer
seen as that signal.
Now there are large houses.
So I think that
what's interesting
is figuring out how do
we capitalize on that
and sort of change the nature
of dialogue that happens
in communities around
what level of density
their comfortable with.
KARA MILLER: You spend your
days thinking about problems.
Like, here are the
problems with cities,
and how do we solve them, right?
Traffic and cars have
come up several times.
We've only been talking
for a few minutes.
Is the car and traffic
your number one problem?
Are there other things
you put on that?
Like this is the top.
These are serious
problems in cities.
NIGEL JACOB: The sort of traffic
and cars are a big problem.
But I would say issues related
to education, making sure
that children graduate school
on time, get into college,
like those kinds of more
intimate, personal kind
of issues, the things
that impact people's lives
most directly, I would
rank0 at the top.
I would say that cars
and infrastructure,
or cars and transportation
for once you get going.
And they tend to be either
a choke point or an enabler
for the growth of communities.
KARA MILLER: OK, so let's
look at some of the stuff
that you guys have
been working on.
And people listening here and
people listening on YouTube,
if you have questions,
you can tweet them.
Mark monitoring
them at @ihubradio.
You can also, if you're
listening at Google,
you can use the Dory to
submit those questions.
And if you're in the
audience, think of them.
We've got microphones here.
We will soon go
to your questions.
So the first thing
here we want to look at
is something that you're working
on, Kent, at the Media Lab.
And this speaks to
this idea of like how
do you make a city a little
bit more self-sufficient?
How do you make
good use of space--
what you were talking
about in terms of density.
So putting a farm in a
city-- talk a little bit
about some of your
experiment here.
KENT LARSON: So we
come at this project
from different directions.
On the one hand,
it's about jobs.
It's about bringing clean
manufacturing into the city,
increasing the
diversity of jobs.
We pick this, in large
part, because if you
can grow fresh produce
in the city efficiently,
increase people's
relationship to their food,
like in medieval city--
I mean, you know, food
was all around you-- and
develop a product that's
consumed locally-- so you
produce and consume locally.
It's like the perfect
manufacturing.
By the way, we think we
can get to doing this
with 10% of the water, 60%
of the fertilizer, ultimately
less energy, particularly if
you consider the supply chain.
Right now, we're flying
vegetables in from Mexico.
Here you can grow food--
high-quality food,
pharmaceutical purity,
no pesticides, maybe two
or three times the
nutrient value-- right
in the city in a visible way.
Everybody wins.
KARA MILLER: Is it
is it realistic,
and is a cost-effective
to put it
farms in a kind of a high rise
building, which is basically
the image that you have here?
KENT LARSON: Well,
we'll have real metrics
when we complete the
studies that we're doing.
But this is on the facade
of the Media Lab building.
So we did it there to
collect all the data
so we can answer that
question definitively.
I do think that it
is cost-effective,
if you factor in that about
half of the vegetables that
come from remote area spoil
in transit, and much of it
rots on the shelf,
and it's picked when
it's green so it doesn't spoil.
And if you can recycle
the water and not
have it evaporate and go into
the ground table, et cetera,
then I think the
numbers will prove out,
particularly for really,
high-value, desirable
vegetables that require a lot
of refrigeration, for example,
to ship.
KARA MILLER: OK, let's
look at the next one here.
So this is a project that
you're working on, Park Boston.
I'm hoping this
is going to mean I
don't have to look for
parking anymore and circle
the block forever.
What's your aim here?
NIGEL JACOB: Sure, so I
just want to say a couple
minutes about who we are.
So I co-run a group at Boston
City Hall called the Mayor's
Office of New Urban Mechanics.
Our job is to be
the experimentalists
in local government.
And so we're always looking
for experiments, prototypes,
that we can role out into
the world that will actually
push the envelope in terms
of the kinds of services
that the city delivers.
And one of the things that
we hear loud and clear,
we've all talked about
this, is that the parking
is a horrible
experience for anyone
driving through the city.
Transportation, generally,
is a big problem.
And so the way that
New Urban Mechanics
would go about
addressing this issue
is to focus on the
user experience first.
I mean, the system needs
to be changed radically,
but that will require
months and possibly
years to kind of overhaul the
Boston infrastructure to be
truly 21st century.
But in the meantime, there's
lots of like tweaks and hacks
that we can introduce
into the system
to change people's
daily experience.
And so Park Boston is an
app that we rolled out
late last year.
And the intent is to make
it as easy as possible
for you to pay for parking.
So unfortunately,
it doesn't magically
do away with the
parking problem,
but it is a small
step in the direction
of turning the parking
experience into one that
isn't bad and doesn't want to
generate anger and road rage
and that kind of thing.
KARA MILLER: Do
you think that some
of the stresses on
cities-- we certainly
saw it in Boston this winter.
We got this tremendous
amount of snow,
put a lot of stress, not only
on traffic, which it certainly
did, but also people
couldn't get anywhere
via public transportation.
That was really
hard to do, as well.
Do you think at
the stresses that
are being put on cities, by
the fact that they're really
popular now, is something
that government is really
struggling to keep up with?
NIGEL JACOB: I certainly
think that any kind of stress
to the system government
will either recoil from it
or respond more positively
see it as a challenge.
And so I would say
Mayor Walsh has
been very clear that this is
an opportunity to push change.
So we are trying,
as much as we can,
to use this as an opportunity
to rethink snow operations
and to rethink the kinds
of information and data
and technology that we put
in the hands of people that
are actually out there
driving those snow plows,
rethinking the way that we
melt snow, rethinking the way
that we get rid of it.
It's interesting.
Like one of the big
concepts now for thinking
about the application
of technology to cities
has been this concept
of the 'smart' city.
And I've never heard
snow operations
in the smart city's concept.
It's always about blinking
lights and sensors and so on.
But it's never about how
do you get rid of snow
faster, better, cheaper,
more effectively in a way
that the anger everyone.
KARA MILLER: I know, and that's
a major, major challenge.
Kent, when you look
at these issues,
and you think about what we
were talking about a little bit
before, this sort of divergence
between the people who once
lived in cities-- if you
went back 40, 50 years
and looked at who
lived in cities,
it was often the people
who couldn't afford
to live out in the suburbs.
Do you see those people, who
once lived in cities, not being
able to find a
place in the cities
because the jobs in
cities have changed
and the affordability
issues have changed?
And we see those people, then,
moving out to the suburbs.
KENT LARSON: Well, you see that.
We work a lot in Europe.
We have a relationship
with Hamburg and Andorra.
And I think in Europe
they do a much better job
of dealing with those
issues, with public policy,
and making sure that you
have equity in cities.
It's a tricky balance.
Because if you leave
it to the market,
you will have gentrification
and people without means
will have to leave.
And to a certain
extent, that's just
the natural flow of things.
But it reaches a point where
it kills innovation in city.
It kills interaction.
Cities are all about
creative interactions
and strong social ties that
leads to an exchange of ideas,
which, if you're lucky, leads
to Google's being formed
and innovative companies.
What's happening in many
cities in the US and Europe--
and London's that way-- all
of the people, the creatives,
are leaving the city, and you're
left with mainly rich people
in corporate offices,
and I think that really
does kill innovation.
And, by the way, cars
kill innovation, too.
KARA MILLER: It's
interesting, a great tech
mind, who is the CEO of a
company, a fairly small company
but not super small, was
complaining to me one time
and saying, you
know, I used to be
out-- he used to be in
Central Square in Cambridge.
And then this
company got too big,
and he was going to move
it out to the suburbs,
because that's what he had
done with his previous company,
and everybody loved that.
And multiple engineers
came to him and said,
if you move this company
out to the suburbs,
I am not working here anymore.
And he was like,
well, then I guess
I'm keeping it in the city.
And he moved to the
Innovation District,
and he was kind of
griping to me and saying,
you know, when I
first worked here,
you could get a
sandwich at lunch.
Now the lines are so long.
You could get out of here
at the end of the day.
Now the traffic is so bad.
So you said the
creatives are leaving
and the rich people are left.
What kind of jobs-- I'm
interested in hearing
from both of you.
What kind of jobs are coming to
the city, and what kind of jobs
are leaving the city?
KENT LARSON: Well,
it depends what city.
I mean, around here
it's tech jobs.
KARA MILLER: Are coming.
KENT LARSON: They're coming,
and that's what you mostly find.
But there are
cities now that are
focused on clean manufacturing
coming back into the city.
There are tremendous
opportunities for that.
I think we had this loss of
those kind of jobs to China.
I think technology and increased
standard livings in China,
a lot of things, are
enabling those kind of jobs
to come back.
And a lot of those can
come back into the city.
Because rather than
dirty, noisy factories
that have to be out
of the city, you
have clean, high-tech
manufacturing
that can come into the city.
And the urban
agriculture, for us,
is just what we
picked as an example
of a great clean
manufacturing opportunity.
But there are many
things-- prototyping,
fab labs, small runs
of complex parts,
technology manufacturing.
There are all kinds of things
that can come into the city.
It takes good public
policy to encourage that.
I don't think
anything that we're
talking about can be solved
by design alone or technology
alone or public policy alone.
It requires all three of
those to come together
in a very creative way.
NIGEL JACOB: So
one of the things
we've begun to see over
the last several years
is a broadening of the
definition of innovation
as it relates to the economy.
So I think increasingly,
when you look at cities,
it's not just the additional
high-tech sort or the biotechs.
We're seeing the food industry.
There's a lot of
innovation there.
There's these
culinary accelerators.
There's a lot of different
flavors of innovation
out there, and the question
is-- if you consider the greater
Boston area, you
consider Kendall Square,
Boston's Innovation District,
the Longwood Medical area,
and so on.
Clearly, those are
centers of innovation
that have worked well.
The question is, how do
you learn the lessons,
or extract the lessons,
from those places
and bring them to
the rest of the city?
And so this is one
of big questions,
I think, facing the concept
of what does a neighborhood
innovation district look like?
That borrows elements of
what's happened in the seaport,
but it doesn't encourage just
straight up gentrification.
So what we're not
talking about here
is how do we bring
start-ups into like Dudley
Square, or something
necessarily, and force
those people out.
But it's how do we encourage
the people in that neighborhood
to start forming
small businesses that
are in the innovatation--
KARA MILLER: NIGEL
JACOB: To be part
of that growth that happens.
I'm going to put you
both on the spot here.
You travel around a lot.
You've seen a lot
different things.
Tell me one or two of like
the coolest things that you've
seen in cities in other
parts of the world
or are maybe other parts of
the country that you think,
wow, we show that here.
It can be just like a gadget.
It can be a building, or
it can be broader idea.
Do you have one, Ken?
KENT LARSON: Well,
there are lot of them.
I love going to be older
cities in Europe, particularly
the centers, because they
evolved before the car,
and they really are these
compact urban neighborhoods.
I spend a lot of
time in Helsinki.
And they have a
great project there.
It's called Kutsuplus,
I think it is.
You can look that up--
its weird Finnish name.
All it is, it's a
shuttle-on-demand system.
It's dynamically routed.
They're increasingly moving away
from fixed route buses or trams
on track.
It's like a multi-passenger
Uber system in a sense,
except it's more
sophisticated, because based
on the calls for
pickup, at your doorstep
and at destination drop off,
it will dynamically route
the shuttles.
And it's all based on
advanced algorithms
and predictive demand modeling.
And I think it points the way
towards very agile, lightweight
systems providing
better services
and getting away from
heavy, expensive centralized
infrastructure.
NIGEL JACOB: Yeah, one
of my favorite examples
is Barcelona for
lots of reasons.
I mean, there's a ton of
innovation happening there
and has for quite awhile.
But one of the elements I've
always found fascinating there
is that they've
essentially created
a program in which technology
developers, startups, companies
large and small can actually
test their technology
essentially on the city.
So when you think about
all the technology that
exists in the streets,
everything from traffic lights
to the physical roads,
this is all technology.
And what they've done is to
create a process and program
in which someone with
a new piece of tech,
whatever that happens
to be, can install
into the physical
environment to gather data,
to improve the people's
experience if the city
and so on.
And I think it creates this
dynamic environment, where
the city itself evolves in a
way that encourages innovation
to happen on the city itself.
So it's not just the city
as a backdrop for innovation
of innovative companies, but
it's also the city literally
as the laboratory for trying--
KARA MILLER: That's fascinating.
I'm going to have-- but right
before we go to questions,
I'm going to have,
Kent, you talk
about-- partially
because it's cool,
because it's like a giant
LEGO model, this model
that you've created
at MIT, but it also
shows you something about
how we behave in cities.
So talk about what this is.
KENT LARSON: Well, this a
model of Kendell Square .
It actually was an animation.
So you'd see things moving if
we were playing the animation.
But one of my
frustrations, coming
from the world of
architecture and planning,
is the master plans
are developed.
Usually great graphics,
nice architecture, but you
don't have a clue how they
will actually function.
How will people behave?
What's the impact on traffic?
Where will people hang out?
Where are the high crime areas?
What's the impact on public
health, on and on and on.
We think that we
can get to a place
where we can model the
city three dimensionally.
In this case, we're using
augmented reality video
projectors to project simulation
onto that three-dimensional
model to actually, in a
data-driven, evidence-based
way, understand
how it will happen,
how all these urban innovations
will impact people in all
the other aspects of life.
I think we can get
to the point where
we can actually score designs.
So I think some of like what's
planned for here in Kendall
Square, I don't think it will
work very well, frankly-- not
enough housing.
It contribute to the innovation
potential of Kendall Square.
The Volpe Center, with this
huge area in Kendall Square,
that really needs to
be carefully designed.
And if it's developed to
the highest and best use
of the land
financially, it will not
work as fostering and
enabling innovation
in what should be the greatest
innovation hub in the world,
I think.
We need to have these tools.
So we're in the
early phases of this.
But it's all about
understanding the data,
using that to inform
the interventions,
and then simulating the
impact with algorithms.
KARA MILLER: Now, is
what we're seeing here,
like is the blue people driving?
KENT LARSON: OK,
this was a study what
would happen in Kendall Square
if you got rid of all cars,
you got rid of all parking,
you got rid of all turn lanes,
and you went to shared-use
autonomous vehicles.
And we've looked at what happens
with private cars, what happens
with autonomous private cars.
Things actually get worse.
I think that's it's big setback.
KARA MILLER: When you have
your self-driving car.
KENT LARSON: Oh, it's terrible.
KARA MILLER: Not a
good thing, which
is interesting because so
many people you talk to,
roboticists, they
all say, it's coming.
And I mean, you kind of see it.
A lot of cars already
are self-parking,
where they parallel
park by themselves.
KENT LARSON: It is coming.
It will have a major impact.
KARA MILLER: Negative impact.
KENT LARSON: It's not--
well, it will either
be a tremendous negative impact
or a tremendous positive impact
or somewhere in between,
depending how it's implemented.
Private autonomous
vehicles, I think,
will kill innovation in cities.
Shared-use autonomous
lightweight electric vehicles
could have a tremendous
positive impact.
KARA MILLER: And is the reason
that the individual autonomous
vehicles are potentially
negative is because people turn
them into their
office, like who cares
how long you're on the
road because you can just
write emails.
KENT LARSON: That they can
encourage sprawl because you
can move farther away.
It can increase trips
because you might
take the car into the office.
It goes home, picks
up your husband,
goes home, picks up your kids.
You go to a fancy
restaurant downtown.
You don't want to
pay $40 for parking.
You just send it spinning
around the block.
KARA MILLER: Send the car home.
KENT LARSON: And everybody
at the restaurant--
I mean, on and on.
Unless you have really good
public policy in place,
it will have a big
negative impact.
KARA MILLER: That's fascinating.
It's like a dimension I think
people don't think quite enough
about.
So let's take some questions
here if you have them.
There are a couple of mics.
And, as I said, if you are
not here, if you're a Googler,
you can send your
question via Dory.
If not, you can tweet it.
LIZ SCHWAB: So I'll get
us started with a question
from the Dory.
The tech industry,
including Google,
are often considered partly
to blame for rising income
inequality in cities.
How can we, companies and
cities, help to mitigate this?
KARA MILLER: Yeah,
either of you.
I mean, there's been
a lot of attention
on this in San Francisco close
to Google's headquarters.
NIGEL JACOB: I mean,
it's a tough one.
I think though,
earlier on, we were
talking with the
idea of how do you
engage communities in a real
dialogue about what density
means.
And I think it's the same
thing in this case as well.
When you've got sort
of these companies
that will have a large footprint
in an urban center in terms
of numbers of people
and also the strain
on the transportation
infrastructure,
there are ways for
those companies
to have conversations with
the community and understand--
and the way that they also
design those buildings,
so they're not these
hermetically sealed kind
of blocks that are just drop
in the middle of a community,
but encouraging
ground level mixed-use
and making it open
to the community.
I think there are
effective ways of doing it.
And so I think that, honestly,
engagement with the community
is really the way forward
for those companies.
KARA MILLER: Want
to get in on that?
KENT LARSON: Well, I think
that's exactly right.
Companies should
be good neighbors.
They should do the right
thing for the community,
and they have the
resources to do it,
and they should be helped by
the government to do that.
I mean, you increase the
density of all the properties
in Kendall Square, but you
impose good public policy
so you get the positive
benefit for the people
that are living there, as
well as the people that would
like to come into the area.
And address traffic
problems with these systems,
et cetera, et cetera.
I think everybody can come
out ahead financially,
and you can achieve equity.
KARA MILLER:
Question right here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm carless
in Cambridge and like it.
But I've noticed
in my area there's
been a lot of development
and discussion about,
well you have to run
traffic reports as far as,
if housing needs
to provide parking
to be built and approved.
And there's been flyers
lately or waivers
about not having to anymore if
it's close to public transit.
And I understand
that and the growth
and close to public transit
and the intent behind it,
but I've done some research and
I can't find a straight answer
on will those people
still be able,
who agree to live
in those units,
still be able to get
on permit parking?
And if they can, I feel
like it kind of takes away
this protection to
promote carlessness,
like I am and I love.
And it just kind of
goes by an honor system,
and it kind of takes away
that safeguard, and I'm sorry.
I'm being opinionated.
What do you think?
NIGEL JACOB: I think there's a
lot of room here to experiment.
I think that we've
often seen parking
as, again, a god-given right.
And I think there
are ways of treating
it more like a
community commodity
that we have to share.
If you look around
the country, there
are different attempts
at doing this.
In some cases,
maybe, do you want
to pay for a resident
parking permit?
In some places,
that's admissible.
In other cases, that's
totally off the table.
I think that the
biggest challenge
that cities face right now is
that the world is changing.
And so the way that we
think about public policy
and regulation has
to change as well.
We need to move out of
this world in which it
is you come up with a codified
set of policies that exist now,
and that maybe in 30 years,
you'll reexamine them.
We need to be, especially
around transportation,
where there are known resources
and sort of pros and cons
that we can experiment with, and
so you can sort of choose zones
where you decide,
well, you know what
we're going to do over here?
On Sundays, we're
going to do something.
Or over here, three
days a week, we
will make these roads one way.
There's lots of things
that we can do and then
learn from what works and then
have that drive the discussion.
KARA MILLER: And New
York has done that.
Some said, we're going to
shut down, whatever, Broadway
or whatever, and we're
going to have a fair.
And you know and
at certain times
traffic is rerouted
in a different way.
People's lives are oriented
People can walk down these main
thoroughfare that normally they
wouldn't be able to.
Has that worked, that
kind of experiment?
NIGEL JACOB: Yeah,
those experiments
have been very successful.
I mean, sometimes they fail.
But I think that one of the
advantages of something-- I
don't know if you can see it.
But like, the LEGO
model-- what's it called?
KENT LARSON: City Scope.
NIGEL JACOB: City Scope-- one
of the advantages of City Scope
is that it allows a community
to take essentially policy
impact out of the realm
of the guesstimate.
I think it will
do such and such.
Whereas this can give people
a much more specific sense,
and intuitive sense, as far
as if there are these changes,
what can we expect
from the community?
Like, what would it be like
to walk in that community?
Am I dodging cars, or is it
sort of a leisurely stroll,
and so on?
KENT LARSON: So one project
we're really excited about,
because it gives
us an opportunity
to work with these
guys in the city,
we have a grant from
the Barr Foundation,
and we will be testing
a process where
you engage with the community
about what their community
might be in the future.
And rather than quibbling
about whether that building's
too tall, you start with, what
kind of community do you want?
What kind of vibrancy
on the street?
What kind of people
should live here?
Do you do want a grocery
store and a pharmacy?
Well, that might require
an increase in density
to get the number of
people that will support
that, where they will come in.
But do that just in
terms of quality of life
and the vision
for the community.
Then you work backwards
into the zoning.
Most of the time, the
zoning ordinance--
I mean, we're talking about a
really antiquated, primitive,
crude system.
NIGEL JACOB: At best.
KENT LARSON: At best, and
we should throw most of it
out and start over.
I think you could develop
a zoning ordinance that's
more of an algorithm
than prescriptive.
It's absolutely crazy that
you have a micro unit that
requires a parking space
to be associated with,
even if the marketing studies
show that person's not
likely to drive.
KARA MILLER: Well, then
you realize, I mean,
if you have a ton of
micro units in a building,
you very quickly run out
of space if people are just
ringing the block.
There's only so much space
ringing the block for cars,
right?
KENT LARSON: Right, so the city
of Cambridge, or any community,
could decide well, OK, if you
are agreeing of signing a lease
to live in this building,
that does not entitle you
to a parking permit.
KARA MILLER:
Question right here.
AUDIENCE: I understand
that in December, Boston
was chosen as one of the
100 Resilient Cities Effort
by the Rockefeller Foundation.
That doesn't necessarily mean
that is resilient, but more
that it has some good
challenges and some people who
are thinking about that
within the city structure
and ready to take some actions.
Could you comment on this
concept of flexibility
to withstand shocks and so on?
NIGEL JACOB: Sure, and
that's a great one.
So resilience is
a concept that has
been talked a lot of over the
last several years for cities.
As everything from climate
change to a flaky stock market,
making sure--
KARA MILLER: Like snow.
NIGEL JACOB: Yeah, snow
would be a good example.
Ensuring that are cities
are resilient to these kinds
of shocks to the
system is increasingly
a core part of how we have
to think about our future.
And so that can mean
many different things.
It's not just about--
at one point, that
was equated to sustainability.
But there's so much
more that goes into it.
There's everything from
looking at the distribution
of resources-- how far I'm
sourcing things from-- to also
issues of equity.
A city that has a history of
a lack of equity, like Boston
does, how do we think about
the people's sense of safety
in a neighborhood?
Because that will determine a
great deal as far as if there's
any shock to the system,
will that neighborhood
dissolve into chaos and looting?
So it's in our
interest to figure out
what are the elements that
go into a safe city that's
sustainable, that's equitable,
in which people can work
their way up to the middle class
if you're not there already,
and then beyond--
all those things.
It's a hard one.
But I think that Boston
is going to be-- we're
going to starting
our perspective,
looking at some of
our historical issues
around equity.
KARA MILLER: I don't know if
we have another question right
now, but if we
don't, I want to go
to, I think it's the fifth
slide, Street Bump, yeah.
So this is a really
cool app that you guys
created in the Office
of New Urban Mechanics.
Talk a little bit about,
basically, finding potholes.
NIGEL JACOB: Sure, so one
of the things that we've
been interested-- so again,
a lot of what we focus on
in New Urban Mechanics
are hacks that
get at your day-to-day
experience of the city.
And so if you are
driving, bumpy roads
can have all kinds
of repercussions
on sort of traffic flow and
also people's level of anxiety
and anger.
So it's in our
interest to not have
people experiencing road rage.
And so the idea was for
the last several years,
we've been running another app
that we had great response to.
It's called Citizens
Connect, and it's really
become a primary
channel for residents
telling the city
things that need to be
fixed-- so potholes and so on.
But one of the pieces of
feedback we started getting
was what it was even easier?
So right now, the app
is pretty simple to use.
But essentially, you can't
be driving and doing this.
Please don't drive and
use Citizens Connect.
But you have to stop
and do something, right?
See the pothole or the graffiti?
Well, what if it was
even easier than that?
What if there was
something running
on your phone that was gathering
data from the accelerometers.
So that's the idea
behind Street Bump.
It's an app that you choose
to download, obviously.
And when we think about
this piece of technology,
because we are a
government, there's
a different level
of design thinking
that has to go into it.
So, for example, having this
thing run in the background,
when we started talking
to potential users,
they very quickly
got freaked out there
would be this
government app running
in the back on your phone, and
maybe forget that it's there,
then it pops up one day.
It's a great.
Instead, the idea was we
really see this technology
as a new kind of volunteerism.
We've been calling
it data volunteerism.
And the idea-- or
data donation rather.
And the idea here is that as we
go about our day-to-day lives,
we're gathering data
all the time, obviously,
with all the devices that
we have all over our bodies.
And what if you could
use some of that data
to make society better, to
make everyone else's experience
better So that's the
idea of Street Bump.
It's still in the R&D phase.
We're doing a bunch of sort
of data mining R&D on it.
But the idea is that
it becomes a new kind
of volunteer channel for people
as they move through the city.
So the idea is that you're
running the app on your phone
and driving around the
city-- maybe driving less.
And whenever the algorithm
detects something
that needs fixing, it'll
ultimately send that issue
into the city to be fixed.
There's an automated back end.
So that's sort of
the short story.
KARA MILLER: But
it's interesting
that you tapped into an
accelerometer that's already
in everybody's phone to record
when you dip into the pothole.
And then you don't send
trucks around looking to fill
potholes, like where are they?
They already know, kind
of, where they are.
NIGEL JACOB: The
traditional a way
of doing this, you
should see this.
You should Google this.
They have mischaracterized
the industry,
and I apologize, industry.
But essentially, they
were these trucks
that used to drive around.
So maybe this is
trailing edge technology,
but I like this story anyway.
Essentially, they would
have this metal bar attached
to the back of the
truck, and they were
chains connected to that bar.
And as it was driving
over the road,
the chains would
be on the ground.
And so as you're
driving, obviously,
the bumpier the road,
the more the chains
would be jumping up and down.
And there was an acoustic
coupler attached to the bar.
So the noisier that the chains
were, you knew the worse
the road was.
And I was like, that's clever,
but that seems like old school
technology.
And then, of course,
when you do those things,
they're not cheap,
and it gives you
a moment-in-time view as to
what's happening in the city.
Here we're looking
at how do we get
a much more kind of real-time,
up-to-date, by-the-minute sense
as to what the quality
of the roads are.
KARA MILLER: I don't know if
there's any more questions
out here or on the Dory.
Is there one?
OK.
AUDIENCE: So this was
touched on a little bit
already with Helsinki
and Barcelona,
but maybe you can
elaborate, if you so choose.
What global cities are on the
cutting-edge of innovation,
and what are they doing?
NIGEL JACOB: I
mean, there's lots.
I think any city
that's experiencing
any kind of rapid
urbanization has
to be working in different ways.
On the high end,
we always end up
talking about a city
like Singapore that
has a great, incredible latitude
in terms of how they think
about the physical
infrastructure
if the city and the amount of
resources they can put into it.
And so they're doing
incredible things
around their built environment.
The challenge for those of
us in this part of the world
is how do we retrofit
cities to be innovative.
And oftentimes, the tools
that we have at our disposal
are just very
different, and they're
much more around
policy hacks that
can drive interesting
development projects and so on.
And so certainly, I
would say, New York.
The example you gave
is a perfect example.
That's not a technology thing,
but it's a positive thing,
and it can have big
impact in terms of how
people experience the city.
I would say cities like Rio are
doing really interesting things
in how they think
about capturing data.
KARA MILLER: Actually, I was
just going to ask you about
Rio, and I don't know if
Singapore's doing this too,
but my sense is
in China, in Rio,
and other places that now when
things are built-- and, I mean,
China's a good example because
they're just like building
massive cities all
the time from scratch,
which must people aren't--
there putting tons of sensors
throughout, so that you can have
a like master control center
and have a sense of there's
stress on that bridge.
Let's go fix it before
the bridge collapses.
Kent, is that
widespread-- this idea
of like putting
sensors inside things,
so that you can sit
somewhere in a room
and look at the state
of all these sensors?
KENT LARSON: That's the
conventional smart cities
approach-- put a lot of sensors
out, have an early warning
system, have a control
center, like in a power plant,
and you can fix the problems.
You can optimize traffic.
And that that's all
really good, but I
don't think it's sufficient.
They're looking at optimizing
throughput on cars.
We'd much rather
get rid of cars.
I think that you talk
about the cities that
are doing a-- Singapore
has be on the list.
I love Hong Kong
and the way they've
managed density and proximity
and diversity and the issues
that we're looking at.
But the most impressive work
that I have experienced,
I think, are in the older
cities in Northern Europe.
It's Copenhagen and Amsterdam
and Helsinki and Hamburg.
Et cetera.
They're sophisticated.
They have good public policy.
They have a more of
a socialist attitude
so they deal with
issues of equity.
And they're very
sophisticated with respect
to technology, a very
educated society.
So I think that's where things
will get prototyped and tested
in living labs.
But a lot of the ideas
are coming from the US.
That's where they're
getting tested.
And I think,
ultimately, they'll be
deployed at scale in the
Middle East and in China.
They'll probably build
all the technology
and sell it back to us.
KARA MILLER: Look
forward to that.
One final question
for you-- so let's
say you got a few minutes
with President Obama.
He was like, I don't
have much time.
I have to get my
security briefing.
But tell me-- I'm willing
to try to do one thing,
and it can be crazy, out there,
whatever-- one thing to make
cities more innovative and
dynamic, what would you
like me to do?
Whoever wants to
start, what would you--
KENT LARSON: Do it.
I think I'd focus on housing.
I think that's where the
innovation is most needed,
because you won't have the
kind of diversity and equity
in a city unless you
address the housing problem.
And I'm very impressed
with Mayor Walsh's housing
initiative.
We're working together
on that right now,
and I think we have
some really good ideas.
I think everything else
can come along afterwards.
KARA MILLER: That
means more homes
in the city, denser,
figuring out ways
to make people happily
live in small places
and a lot of people.
KENT LARSON: And there's
an advanced technology play
at multiple dimensions to
make the experience of living
in a small space fantastic,
and transformable elements
so they're almost magical.
And that requires all
kinds of new technologies.
NIGEL JACOB: But that will
work only if the housing is
affordable, and middle
class families can actually
buy those homes or
rent those homes.
And so thinking not only about
the construction techniques,
but like the innovative
models around financing
and that sort of thing
will also be important.
I would say, if I had some
advice for the President--
I don't know if
this is necessarily
a thing for the
President-- but when
we talk about
cities in this way,
I think we often do
so with the mindset
that there's
inherent competition,
that the primary force
at work between cities
is that of competition.
And I think it is
true a certain degree,
but it's also very artificial.
And I think that cities have far
more to learn from one another
then we have to sort
of be poaching things
from each other.
And so I think that
all these things
that we've been talking about,
finding more effective ways
for us to work together and
to collaborate, to share
innovations, to share risks
in different kinds of projects
is a direction that we need our
cities to be moving towards.
KARA MILLER: So
Pittsburgh's good ideas
get imported to Boston, and
then they get imported to LA.
NIGEL JACOB: That's right.
In many cases, one of
the interesting things
that we've seen, in the
case of immigration,
the models have just changed.
Where 100 years
ago, people would
leave their country of
origin, come to the New World,
say, and their interaction
with their country of origin
was very limited.
They might send letters back.
But nowadays, it just doesn't
work that way anymore.
People are often
trinational, binational,
where they are spending part
of their year in one country
and then another in the new
country or in the new city,
in particular.
And they're even changing
how the access services.
They might access
financial services--
they might do all their
banking in Sao Paolo,
but they do all their
health services in Boston.
And so we need to be looking
to these sort of city networks
as really the source of where we
can be looking for innovation.
KENT LARSON: Yeah, building
on that, the other thing
I'd ask Obama to
focus on is right now,
the wheel is being reinvented
all different places
all over the world.
There are mechanisms for
cities to share best practices,
but I think we need
a platform that
is shared for design
tools that are shared,
solutions that are
shared, that are
linked to three-dimensional
models and databases,
simulation tools.
So when Nigel tries
something in Boston,
they can take the same
idea, and it's not just
a vague kind of
best practice, it's
actually the solution embodied
in data and algorithms
and in all the other
things in public policy
and financial models, et cetera.
And I think we're
in the dark ages.
We're sharing reports
and scribbles.
Let's share real solutions.
KARA MILLER: Kent Larson
from MIT's Media Lab,
Nigel Jacob from the Office
of New Urban Mechanics at City
Hall, thank you both so much.
This was a great
discussion, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And thanks to
Google for hosting.
Thanks to you for coming
out and for your questions.